Isis which I find is often very tricky
to map to map onto a GPU if you've got
depending on what the function is if you
got out elements of size where one sort
of item of work is of a size between ten
and a thousand elements it can be tricky
to map onto the thread the parallel
thread execution model because you
typically need to use a whole block of
threads to work together on a chunk of
data that size I always find that really
fiddly to implement I don't necessarily
knit I'm going to get good performance
the other thing to be aware of is if you
see that a lot of the time the D types
are all float64 that's very slow on
consumer GPUs so if that's the hard way
you've got access to maybe don't look at
you trying to use GPU first as an
alternative to using GPU if you've got
lots of small pieces of data in many
function calls perhaps you can adjust
the interfaces of your functions so that
instead of passing one item of data to
it at a time perhaps you can make a
batch a batch of items are data and then
doing all that work in one function call
rather than multiple function calls then
once you've done that perhaps you can
get more performance out of it by using
numbers jit or vectorized decorators to
compile that batched function another
thing you might see is that you might
have a very generic function that's
often called with data shapes or water
or side ball shapes or types that could
be a particular special case for example
of that would be if you perhaps if you
had and a multi-dimensional solver but
you saw that you were calling it to do
1d solves all the time perhaps it would
make more sense if that's if that's a
simple if that's a simpler case to
implement to implement and 1d so over
and use that where it's applicable so
that's it for the accelerate day to
profiler and I will talk a little bit
about intel vtune i think because I'm
already running short on time I'll talk
a bit about V 2 i'll skip over the sort
of demo bit that I had so reaching is
quite a different tool to the Python
standard library and accelerate data
profile is there event-based profilers
so every time something happens it
records it records that that happened so
V tune in just something little bit
different at regular intervals
it will sample the cost I can see what's
being being done and then record that
and then at the end of the execution it
can use all the samples to build a
statistical profile of what's going on
that's got the advantage that it's quite
low overhead but and you can even tweak
the amount of overhead by just in the
sample interval but that doesn't mean
that any profile it produces is less
than one hundred percent accurate that
doesn't really matter in practice most
of the time the profile I was accurate
enough that you can use the information
to guide you anyway so it had been
experimented with experimenting with it
a little bit recently so what I was
going to talk about was just a little
bit of the things i'd found I could use
it for and what it seemed to be useful
for one of the things that I did like is
that it gives you this single user
interface an or one place if you pat if
you're profiling mixed Python code and
native code I've tried it with anaconda
and it seems to just work out of the box
with anaconda I've also tried it with my
system Python 3 and it seems to work
with that as well I haven't tried it
with Python 2 because no one's using
that anymore are they so what I think
I'll do is just skip out the whole eggs
thought I'll just try and go over this
very fast because well idea what ever
done
instead of going through the whole
example just a couple of examples of
some of the views that it can give you
to try and put it down a bit so when you
finish execute it and give this this
summary of the utilization of your CPU
so you can see how long feel what port
in the program's execution it for what
portion of the program's execution how
well with your CPU is utilized you can
also drill down a little bit more see
what see what particular processes were
doing at any point in time of the
execution of your program that looks so
that tells you what's happening at
different phases in your program but it
doesn't tell you anything about what
particular functions doing so you can
then drill down a bit by looking at the
function summary and that will give you
a list of the individual functions of
how well the the CPU is utilized during
each of those functions as well in this
particular profile not many Python
functions are showing near the top but
if I scroll down a bit that I could see
that there were some Python functions
there sometimes you have to ask it seems
like you have to sometimes it's expanded
a native method like pi c function call
or something anything eval to be able to
see it to be able to see some of the
python code so i would say that v tunas
the tool to use if you got to profile a
mix of native or python code or if
you're using multi processes or threads
and trying to do that by releasing by
releasing the gill so you might think
it's difficult to use multi threading in
Python because of the global interpreter
lock but it turns out that a lot of
libraries that you commonly use in data
science have at least some functions
that would release the gill or if you're
writing your own code using number or
siphon then you could then you could
also release the girl yourself using no
Gil so I have skimmed over that so
quickly but if anyone's interested in
beach I'll be happy to talk about that
and later just coming up a chat with me
and so for the rest of the talk I was
going to talk about the new number
features since last year so when I gave
the tutorial last year the current
version number was not 118 run
25 now the pace of development seems to
go quite fast so this is just a
selection of some of the new features
I'm going to talk a bit about the first
four because these are the ones that I
thought that I could explain and give
some guidance on the last three are
interesting as well i'll talk about them
a little bit at the end so before I do
that I'm just gonna leave a very quick
introduction to number so number is a
just-in-time compiler for Python so you
can apply to specific Python functions
that you're interested in speeding up by
using the decorator just decorate your
function with jit and then it will
compile it because its main goal is to
make array or into computing fast
there's been a lot of work going to make
it support numpy as well as possible so
a lot of support for a lot of numpy
functions and array operations you can
get quite a good speed up with it so
this is an example of a Mandelbrot
function if we just take a pure Python
version running on CP Iceland and run
that measure the execution time we say
that runs a one-time speed if we if we
use the number two jet compile it then
you can get speed over 120 times now not
it's not necessarily going to be the
case that you can get such a huge speed
up every time but you can get a lot of
big speed ups for a lot of different
codes with it so that's one way of using
number to use the JIT decorator to
compile a function the other way to use
it is to use its vectorized decorator so
what vectorize does is it'll take a
function that you write in Python that
operates on scalars and then it will
compile them down to a function that's
automatically applied element wise to
erase that get passed to it and that's
called a universal function or a you
funk what's new here is the ability to
generate you flunks with a vectorized
decorator that automatically execute in
power or on a on a keyword of GPU so
here I've got two examples of a function
that computes relative difference one
using the doing in cereal and then one
doing it in parallel so to make it to
create a parallel or QD you think you
just use the target argument so for
parallel one targeting cuz parallel or
fukuda to i'll get equals Q de and I did
a quick benchmark of this on my laptop
and
comparing the patent the parrot the
serial version and the parallel version
the parallel version was about twice as
fast on my laptop which has got to real
course so for a small amount of work if
you're using a vectorized function you
can get a decent speed up there just by
adding the target to create a parallel
you think so it's fairly straightforward
to use them once you've once you graphed
how to use the vectorize decorator there
are a couple of other things to be aware
of one is that normally you can just
write a function with the vectorized
decorator and not specify what the types
of the arguments are and i'll just work
was kind of a not yet implemented thing
where if you use if you just use the
parallel target with vector eyes and
don't specify what the types the
arguments are going to be the new front
won't work so you need to pass in a list
of what the argument types are going to
be there is an issue open for that sir
you can check back on that issue it
should get close at some point in the
future and then you should just be able
to use vector eyes with the parallel
target without specifying what the
argument types are if you're using that
target you should get a speed up for all
but the most simple functions if you've
got a really simple function then it's
not going to be bound it's not going to
be sort of computationally pound so
adding more CPU course to the same
problem is not going to remove the
bottleneck if you're thinking about
using the CUDA target instead you just
need to be aware that it's going to be
an overhead when you because it has to
copy data to the GPU run the new Frank
and then copy the result back so you
need to have a slightly more complex
function to be able to get a speed up
that said it's quite easy to experiment
with the different targets just by
changing target use parallel or target
equals Q de so what you can do is just
to experiment with them and see which
one runs fastest for your use case
another new feature in number is
generated functions so the problem the
problem that one of the problems that
you had a number before was if you if
you wanted to create a function that did
different things for different types you
couldn't do that if you try to write a
function that way then you would get a
type error it's possible to write a
function does the same thing two
different types
but not different things to different
types so the generated functions are
number are partly inspired by generating
functions in Julia they're not as
powerful because you don't have I think
in Julia have an AST or an expression
tree that you can manipulate but you
can't do that here what you can do is
write a function that customizes the
dispatching of number so that depending
on what types of arguments you have
passed you can dispatch to another
function that does something different
so you can dispatch on the argument type
so a type is a scalar or an array or
something like that or the argument
properties and properties are ever of
them are things like the number of
dimensions or the d-type of the array so
this is a little bit of an abstract
description so I've got a concrete
example of of using a generated function
so what I wanted to try to do was to try
and write a 1 norm function that
computes the one norm of a scalar or a
matrix or a vector depending on what you
pass into it so the implementation of
each of them is a little bit different
because they're all defined differently
mathematically so I could just put the
JIT decorator on each of these and then
they would work if they were cheated but
it would mean that you'd have to use
you'd have to use the right name like
scale of one no more vet to one norm
depending on what you are passing it if
I try to convince into one function with
some branches in and then get that then
I would get a type error for example if
I passed in a scalar number would be
trying to compile this thing which is
taking the shape as if there's going to
be a 2d case but because scalars don't
have a shape than that will give me the
type error so what I can do instead is
user-generated jet function to implement
the want l1 on function so to do that
use the generated get decorator then you
write the function that has an argument
list when you call l1 norm what it's
going to get past is not the actual
argument itself but some objects
representing the type of the arguments
so if i call l1 norm of the scalar then
the function would check
the l1 norm forms and checks if X's is
them is instance of the number type if
so then it should dispatch the scalar 1
norm function if it's been passed an
array type and that that has a property
of ending equal to 1 then it'll return
the vector 1 norm function and then if
Enda ms2 for the scale of one long sorry
the matrix 1 norm function I always like
to have an else Clause as well but just
returns a function that's always going
to throw an error explaining in terms
that i can understand what's gone wrong
so that's how we've defined the l1 norm
function using generated yet let's have
a look at how would call it so in this
example we're calling it so x 0 is a
number or scalar x1 and x2 and the
vector in a matrix so the first three
calls will all succeed just fine because
because we have an implementation that
can be used for each of them if we try
and pass it this this array with three
dimension instead it's going to fall
through two aisles case lobia it'll
raise that type error saying unsupported
type 4 1 norm so that was a very quick
example of a generated jit function the
general guidelines for that i can think
of for using them are there's a lot of
different types and attributes so i
showed it examples of a couple's they're
like number and array and ending you can
look at the code in the number that
types module to see what types and
attributes there are if you find the
ones that I've used in the previous
slide to see what they look like and I
will scroll through and see all the
other types as well so some of those
types of again things like a rake number
integer and so on the buffer type is the
base time for quite a lot of different
things so you can use that to catch a
lot of different cases if you want I do
always think it's good to have that your
fallback case that raises an error
because if you're if you're generated
jit function doesn't find a suitable
case and it just returns norm then you
get a slightly more strange error come
out of number just so Ananse not a
callable object
how am I actually doing for time
so how ever looked Oh brilliant okay
okay so another new feature is jet
classes so the word jet classes in
number before but they were removed as
part of a big really big refactor
focusing on performance and clean up so
there's now jet classes in number again
they're quite different to what they
were before so what you can use them in
number for now is that they can be used
to hold related items together rely
related items of data together within a
single object so one thing you can use
that for is use them a bit like they're
a stripped in C but one of the one of
the things that I think that's
interesting that you can do with them is
to make a transformation where you take
something in what's called an array of
structs layout and then transform it to
us go two strips of arrays layout the
reason you might do that is if you if
your code iterates over a particular
member of every entry of in an array of
structures then this getting this it can
it can increase the performance because
it's a more efficient way to access all
those members so there's a nice article
on what this transformation does from
Intel that you can have a read of in
depth but in simple terms what it does
is it will take a set of objects that
are all next to each other in memory and
then it will sort of transpose their
layout so that all of the same member of
each of those objects and next to each
other in memory so here we've got some
objects the first ones here it's X Y Z
and W or next to each other then the
second one XYZ and w.e next to each
other and so on if we make this
transformation all the x's are next to
each other all the Y's are next to each
other and so on so what I've got on the
next few slides is an example of making
this transformation by using jit classes
so before looking at the jet class
implementation the original layout which
is going to be an array of strips in
this is the original layout using an
array of structs so i did that using a
structured d type in numpy or one way
you could do this is using structured
e-type
so we create a d-type with what the
members of it are and what their types
are and then we could learn instantiate
an array of that that of that structure
then suppose when we wanted to iterate
over all the X's in that array to
initialize them somehow then we can just
write a loop over the array and then
index into it first using the offset
into the array and then what the member
is next how we rewrite that as a
stripped of arrays using a jit class so
to use a jit pass the first thing you do
in you need to produce a specification
and this specification tells number what
the what the names of the members of the
class are and what the and what what
what their types are then to write a jit
class use the jit class decorator and
pass it the specification then you can
write the class as if you write in or
python class I've only included a
constructor here on this example but you
could have other methods on the jit
class as well then you can create an
instance of it use it and just by
calling the classic like you would a
normal python class one thing to note
here is that unlike in the structured
d-type where X Y Zed NW we're all
scalars here one instance of the JIT
class is holding a raise of exes arrays
of wise and arrays of says so this is
the structure of those arrays when it
comes to performing that initialization
that we just that we saw in the previous
item in this sorry when it comes to
initializing all the axes again the
original implementation using the
structure of a raise that's the original
implementation when we're doing it with
the
this implementation is initializing that
this the destructive arrays in the jit
class in the same way we just iterate
over a range so instead of taking the
length of one of the arrays what I often
do with a jit class is to give it lutely
if it's a structural radius to give it a
member called n that just recalls the
length of each of those arrays in it
because I think it's more elegant than
taking the length of randomly of one of
the arrays in it then we can index into
it first by the member and this time by
the offset so we've transposed the
indices just like the layout has been
transposed in memory so some guidelines
for using jit classes I didn't show in
the previous example but because they're
good for holding relate related
collections of related data one thing
you can do is if you have a lot of
arguments to a jit function that always
go together you could create a jit class
just to store those in and then store
all the and then pass you one jet class
argument role but whole set of arguments
so that would reduce the number of
parameters to the JIT function but I
think the more interest in use is to is
to increase performance by making this
array of structs destructive arrays
transformations a couple of things to be
aware of are at the moment using
underscores in this in the member names
frigate class aren't supported but
that's going to be fixed soon another
thing is a common mistake to make when
you use in jet classes is to assign to a
field that's not been declared in the
specification or to assign something
that's the wrong type or a different
type to what was declared in the
specification for example if the
specification set of variables going to
be a member is going to be in 32 but it
was float64 you'll get an error out it
will try and sort of tell you what the
types were and like we can see it says
you can't you can't insert a float star
at a place where there's an eye where
you're supposed to put on I 32 so those
type names do look a little bit
different because they've cooked because
they're llvm type names rather than
something from a higher level but
usually you can guess what it means
so the final feature that was going to
talk about with a number support for
intro for for calling an intercourse eff
i wrapped functions so cff I is a
seafront functioning interface of Python
and I really like using it a lot what it
does it is it will give you rappers to
see libraries but instead of you having
to do something tedious like actually
right in the wrapper yourself it can
just read a sea header file and then
generate the wrapper for you yo man did
give a talk last year a pie later london
NYC extensions are evil but i think it
has a corollary which is the cfi is
really awesome because it makes it so
easy to do these things so it's got two
modes as the end line mode the number
can just work with inline modules or
inline in line cff I wrappers so in line
is when you compile and generate the
wrapper at runtime the out of line is
where you use a previously compiled
wrapper and there is a little bit of
extra work to do with number to get that
to work just so that it can recognize
the type information so do have a quick
demo of using cff a little number
together so the goal of this demo was to
wrap into Intel's vector math library
and use it for a number so vector math
library is a collection of fast
functions that run on run on array so
it's got like a vectorized sigh and
vectorized cosine so on there's a lot of
functions in there so it'd be really
quite time consuming to wrap it by hand
so in general this is this is more an
example of a particular procedure that I
would generally use when tryna rapper
alive with cff I rather than being
focused on the example of vml itself if
you're interested in using that term
functions from vector math libraries
from within Python then it's definitely
worth having a look at accelerate from
continue because they're all wrapped up
in there as as you think so they're a
lot more convenient to use
and so I know I'm running short on time
so I just it's over well no okay okay so
I'll skip that demo but the notebook is
in the exercises so the other number
features that I wasn't gonna talk about
but I think you're interesting is the
ability to extend number before if you
wanted to jitter function and but you
didn't have time to so I've got time on
the mine now home but you didn't but
there was a particular and supported
function then you were stuck what you
can do now is extend number in add
support for that function but it's quite
a complicated topic which would need a
talk in itself there is a detailed
section in the manual though that's
worth having worth having a look at if
you want to extend number recently
there's more improved support for
reusing number in the context of spark
and ask so now cuter works with spark
and dusk and there's been a lot of
performance issues fixed as well also
all the time there's support for more
numpy functions being added so it's
worth checking from time to time the
listed number I supportive function in
the manual with each release to see if
that made it to see if it allows for
more use of number with your use cases
and that's it it's over did I have time
for questions or yes okay hey relative
performance of the two approaches to
vectorize 131 using classes one
oh I osns away all right um I don't
think there's much of a knock-on effect
to using the classes because they're all
compiled to native code any just just
just taking something that's stripped
and just replacing a legit classes is
not necessarily only faster if you make
that transfer if you also use cheat
classes to make that transformation then
it can be faster the reason it can be
faster is because of what Simon was
saying about Cindy oh so in a way it
does provide hints to the compiler
because in this case this would compile
down to a very simple tight loop just in
incremental in dec sorry this case
wouldn't compile down to it just a
simple tight loop incremented index but
this would so